harper's in fredericksburg virginia hey
harper how are you
doing well how y'all doing today better
than i deserve how can we help
so i just started baby step two
uh not too long ago and of course like
everyone else
before i discovered dave you know you do
everything wrong
so trying to undo some of the wrongness
um i have two cars uh one is actually um
well it's a forerunner so
question should i sell the forerunner in
order to expedite
my baby step two efforts are you married
no why do you have two cars
because i don't want to drive the
4runner an hour and a half to work one
way every day
what's your other car it's a
gti volkswagen gti yeah sell the for
water all right sell it
you can't drive it anyway you know go
and drive one car at a time you're one
person yeah
and harbor here's why i say that you
know because i had two cars and i asked
you
yeah i did and i sold it because i was
like i'm single why do i have two cars
you know and i'm like that's that's a
waste of money waste of
insurance waste of gas um so i sold one
of them
um and uh just recently traded one
traded the other one in i only need one
car
so sell it yeah i'm easy enough
and the other thing is here's the thing
you know cars are something about them
um
the price is so big
and they're physically take up space a
lot of space
sure do and so we have this tendency
because of those two things to
emotionally feel like they're forever
it's a stupid car i mean it's it's a
forerunner they're everywhere yeah you
can get you another one
if you want to trade out the volkswagen
later get your for runner you can
absolutely after you get out of debt you
got a big pile of money and you
get something else you want to drive and
wear out whatever you're driving you're
wearing out with that commute
yep but uh um you know and after you're
out of debt if you want to buy a car and
get ready you know
but it just occurred to me like i bought
a truck a while back that i screwed up
on
i i i it had a huge engine it was like
six seven hundred horsepower
it was a beautiful truck too it was a
beast yeah and but
it i had with the raptor before and the
thing rode like crap
and the raptor rides good it's got that
suspension on it and so it's got a good
like a car ride almost to it
and my wife would get in that thing and
of course it's loud i'm a redneck truck
right
and so um she's like yeah this is great
big old loud muffler
rides like i'm in a dead gum wheelbarrow
has no shocks or anything
i'm not going to dinner in this no and
so
i you know i but i felt like i was stuck
in it or something
and i know better and then i thought one
day that's dumb i just stole the truck
it's just a truck get you another one
dave yeah just sell the trucks
i sold the truck got a raptor and that's
what i did you know i had the bmw
750 and then i had my accura and i just
woke up one day i was like
why do i have two cars like why and i'm
only driving one
i'm like just i still just can't drive
to it once it's physically impossible
yeah
so um yeah i that's the thing you can
get you another one and car
my point of the whole thing is we all do
this including me including anthony yes
cars take up a lot of emotional space
because they're physically large and
there's a lot of money
and um and we tend to feel like they're
forever yeah and
it's a forerunner crap you can get seven
of them later yeah it's not a big deal
um yeah i would sell it good good
question though
really good question because it brings
up a good discussion